I'm going to try something today that's very
important and will certainly be useful, but
I don't know how much people, people
will be entertained by it, which is that I'm
going to go through some of the propaganda
that we've been hearing from Republicans who
defend Donald Trump and are of course against
his impeachment conviction in the current
Senate impeachment trial.
And bear with me because I do think this is
going to shed a ton of light on what we've
been seeing.
And it's also going to show you how the pro
Trump right is developing their strategy around
disconfirming the public on the impeachment
of Donald Trump.
And what we saw during the Senate impeachment
trial is that during the breaks, when they
have these 15 to 45 minute breaks in the proceeding,
senators and members of the house will sometimes
talk to the press and basically the term Gish
Gallop is representative of what we've been
seeing in the Senate trial, uh, from Donald
Trump's lawyers and also outside of it from
Republican lawmakers.
During these little press avails.
Gish Gallop is defined as a technique used
during debate that focuses on overwhelming
an opponent with as many arguments as possible
without regard for the accuracy or the strength
of those arguments.
So during the presentations by Donald Trump's
lawyers over the last couple of days, the
attorneys will get up there and they'll say
there was no pressure on the Ukrainian president
because he said there was no pressure.
But anyway, the military aid was released
and abusive power isn't an impeachable offense
and there's no crime.
And Adam Schiff won't testify and they had
secret basement meetings and we have no firsthand
testimony.
And back in 1996 when bill Clinton was being
impeached, Jerry Nadler said this thing or
that thing or whatever the case may be, it's
so much, and the way that it's supposed to
work on you and it is working on a lot of
people, is that you say, wow, that's a lot.
I guess they're right.
I don't know how those things are related
because they're not, of course, I don't know
how those things relate to the impeachment
of Donald Trump because they don't, but it
sounds overwhelming.
That's a lot of stuff.
I guess Donald Trump isn't guilty of any kind
of wrongdoing and this has been a huge challenge
to us in covering the Senate trial live because
it's impossible to go point by point without
then missing a ton of stuff that they continue
to say.
So let's try just one of these in detail.
We'll go through what was said.
This example is Congresswoman Elise Stefanik.
She's a Republican from New York.
During one of these breaks in the proceedings
yesterday, a reporter asks a question and
she jumps in with some Gish Gallop and note
that Donald Trump retweeted this video of
Elise Stefanik.
He loves it, but it's just nonsense.
Take a look at the clip.
Do you run?
You need the 10 sky.
This security assistance to pressure Ukraine
to investigate, but that's okay.
He did not because the aid was released to
Ukraine and there was no investigation and
the president, the president has said that
he did not tie.
There was no conditionality or an insomnia
and in fact testified and we saw that played
out as the president's defense team made the
case that it was presumption, assumption and
guesswork.
So the facts of this case remain the same
in that we have more security assistance for
Ukraine, much more than during the Obama administration.
And there was in fact no investigation into
the Bidens but the administration, the administration
has to lose it.
This was Adam shovel choice, Adam, Adam Schiff,
Adam Schiff, Adam Schiff is clearly scared
that his case is so weak.
Adam Schiff made the decision to withdraw
the subpoena.
This is an unfair unconstitutional and half
baked set of impeachment articles that was
sent over to the Senate [inaudible].
So
that's a ton of stuff and it sounds so open
and shut.
It sounds so overwhelming.
How could she possibly be wrong about what
she's saying?
But let's break it down with the transcript
on the screen.
The reporter asks if the president did tie
the security assistance to pressure Ukraine
to investigate Biden.
That's okay, so she mentions that the aid
was released, but the thing is it was eventually
released because this became a scandal and
they realized it.
So yes, they release the aid, but that's not
exculpatory.
She says the aid was released to say that's
They release the aid because they got caught
and they said, we better release this aid
because it's starting to look really, really
bad.
Then she says, Trump said there was no conditionality.
Well, that's what's being debated here.
Her saying there was no conditionality doesn't
make it true.
Her saying Trump's opinion is there was no
conditionality also doesn't make it true.
She's asserting an opinion as a fact after
saying something that is not actually exculpatory.
She then says, Gordon Sunderland testified
and Trump's defense team says it was presumption,
assumption and guesswork.
Remember, that is not a fact.
She says the people being paid to defend Donald
Trump, his lawyers are attacking Gordon Sunderland's
testimony is merely speculative.
If you go and look at Sunderland's testimony,
he says very clearly there was a quid pro
quo with regard to the announcement of investigating
Joe Biden and I infer that there was likely
one for military aid, although he can't say
for sure you can disagree with Sunland.
You can think Sundland is wrong, that he's
mistaken, that he's lying even, but she States
the argument of Trump's lawyers as fact.
There is a debate about that.
She throws it into the Gish Gallop as fact.
Then she says, we now have more assistance
from Ukraine than under the Obama administration.
Again, that is not evidence for or against
wrongdoing when it comes to the impeachment
articles.
The total aid amounts to different countries
go up and down for a bunch of different reasons.
Over time.
It is a non-sequitur.
She then says there didn't end up being an
investigation into the Bidens.
This is both irrelevant.
If you fail to secure the smear investigation
you wanted, you're not less guilty, you just
failed.
But more importantly, witnesses have said,
Trump didn't care about the investigation
happening.
He only cared about the investigation being
announced.
So saying there was no investigation that
is not exculpatory.
Okay.
Then she switches altogether and this is where
it really escalates.
After being asked about the John Bolton subpoena,
she says, Adam Schiff is scared.
That's not an assertion of any kind of actual
fact that's been presented.
She's using it as an ad hominem.
She's alleging fear as an ad hominem, and
then she says, shift decided not to subpoena
John Bolton implying that the testimony of
John Bolton wouldn't help shift.
And that's why shift decided not to issue
the subpoena.
Now, in reality, they didn't subpoena John
Bolton because due to the obstruction of the
white house, it could take a year for the
forcing of that subpoena to go through the
judiciary.
And by then it would be after the November
election and this entire thing would have
gone nowhere.
It's not evidenced one way or the other about
Donald Trump's guilt that Adam Schiff decided
not to issue a subpoena for John Bolton.
And then again, a non-sequitur she goes to,
this is an unfair, unconstitutional impeachment.
That is not true.
Whether it's unfair, Senate Republicans can
vote and it's certainly not unconstitutional.
So notice how it started with a question.
Would it be okay for Donald Trump to tie military
aid to Ukraine to an investigation of Joe
Biden?
She Gish gallops herself all the way to the
entire thing is unconstitutional.
If you just casually watch those 53 seconds
of Elise Stefanik without really thinking
through each piece, it does sound like, wow,
that's an overwhelming amount of stuff that
she said Trump must be innocent because look
at all those things that she said.
When you break it down, there is no substance
to what she says.
It's conjecture, speculation, mischaracterizations
and complete misdirection to irrelevant.
Nonsequitors.
We could do that with almost any clip of these
Republicans talking to the press during the
breaks.
This is just one clip.
Imagine what there would be if you looked
at others.
Let's do one more briefly.
We won't do it in as much detail because this
relates to witnesses in the trial.
The new line from Republicans about bringing
in witnesses like John Bolton is we'll decide
whether we need to hear more after the trial
is basically done, and this is actually evil.
Genius Republicans have done something insane
to begin with, which is they decided at the
beginning.
We won't decide now about about witnesses
to impeachment or documents or audio visual
records in a normal trial.
At the start of the trial, it's determined
who is on your witness list, what evidence
do you plan to introduce and then both sides
get to prepare their case on the basis of
who's going to be testifying.
Republicans successfully pushed off debating
witnesses until after each side gets 24 hours
to present and senators get 16 hours to ask
questions.
So now they're using this line.
Listen to Republican Senator John Barrasso
here
cause we're going to decide Friday on witnesses,
but it's not going to be a one-sided issue.
We have another day.
We have this evening tomorrow for the president's
case to be presented.
We have 16 hours of questioning on Thursday,
Wednesday and Thursday.
And then ultimately with the question will
come, have we heard enough?
Are we ready to go to final judgment or do
we need to hear from more people?
If we need to hear from more people, it's
going to be a group of individuals, but 51
senators will make that decision on Friday
and not before Friday.
He's
saying, listen, we've had all this questioning,
right?
We're, we're, we've done so much.
We're going to do 24 hours for the managing
impeachment managers.
24 hours for Trump's defense, 16 hours of
questions.
That's 64 hours.
After 64 hours, we'll decide whether we've
heard enough or whether we need to hear from
more people.
This is a completely different framing now
before the trial, which is when they should
discuss witnesses, uh, you can't use the argument
they're now using.
We have a trial.
Who are the witnesses?
Well, you're going to decide based on whether
you want to hear more.
They are going to say 64 hours is a long time.
We've had presentations, we've had questions.
We don't really need more stuff now.
It's already gone on too long because they
blocked the decision about witnesses from
the start.
It's incredibly disingenuous.
It's completely propagandistic and I hope
that this is useful to people in the audience
in understanding how to break down the propaganda
and when the Gish Gallop is so frequently
used, the best thing to do is convert it into
writing like we did and then go through it
piece by piece evaluating each piece taken
altogether.
They want it to sound overwhelmingly exculpatory
when you break it down as we did with Elise
Stefanik, you realize there's nothing there.
There are non exculpatory statements made
as if they were exculpatory.
There is speculation and there are completely
unrelated issues brought up like when asked
would it be okay to tie military aid to a
public announcement of an investigation into
Joe Biden?
She ends up at this entire thing is unconstitutional.
Let me know what you think about these breakdowns.
We have a very special thing going on this
weekend.
It is my birthday on Sunday.
We are doing a huge membership discount on
my birthday.
If you want to be notified about it, get on
our mailing list by signing up@davidpakman.com
you just put in your email address.
Very easy.
You'll be on the mailing list.
Sunday you will get an email
with this disgusting membership discount it.
I can't even tell you what it is because it
makes me feel ill.
It's such a huge discount, but I invite you
to partake.
Just
get
on
our mailing list and you'll be notified on
Sunday